der nächste tagesordnungspunkt der
betrifft uns alle
nämlich der tagesordnungspunkt
energiepreise die oppositionsfraktionen
haben jeweils 100 anträge vorgelegt
explosionen bei den energiepreisen
bekämpfen zeitnah wirksam und gericht
entlasten das fordert die cdu csu die
linke verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
vor energiepreissteigerungen schützen
und die afg hat ein antrag der heißt
kraftstoffpreise sinken wirtschaft
unterstützen wirtschaftskrise verhindern
und der erste redner wird ihnen sehr
bekannt vorkommen es ist nämlich jens
spahn es geht hier nicht mehr um
gesundheit das ist so üblich in ein
minister aus dem amt ausgeschieden sie
wechselt er quasi das ressort jens spahn
ist jetzt der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion für den bereich
wirtschaft und energie und die ganze
debatte hier dauert 67 minuten und
dürfte glaube ich jeden verbraucher
interessieren die opposition kritisiert
eben dass die koalition zu wenig tue um
die verbraucher zu entlasten
dabei hat die koalition ja beim
heizkostenzuschuss schon eine entlastung
vorgenommen und jetzt also jens spahn
quasi in ganz neuer funktionen und
kollegen ich möchte zu beginn der
debatte drei punkte ansprechen erstens
ganz grundsätzlich es gibt drei themen
die die bürgerinnen und bürger dieser
tage ganz besonders beschäftigen
russland ukraine kroner explodierender
energiepreise zu allen drei themen
finden in dieser woche hier im deutschen
bundestag debatten statt das ist gut
aber
sie werden hier nur diskutiert weil wir
die union die opposition sie hier zum
thema machen und
dass es noch bemerkenswerter
und das ist noch bemerkenswerter zu all
diesen drei themen ukraine russland
corona und auch zu den explodierenden
energiepreisen hat die regierung haben
die minister der regierung anscheinend
hier nichts zu sagen sie haben in der
koalition viel über parlamentarismus in
den koalitionsvertrag geschrieben haben
viel kluges dazugehört parlamentarismus
stärkt man vor allem dadurch dass man
ihnen lebt in dem die debatten hier im
deutschen bundestag stattfindet die
regierung sich hier im deutschen
bundestag erklärt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
zweitens zur explosion der energiepreise
sei eines vorneweg gesagt dass die
preise steigen liegt offenkundig nicht
in der verantwortung der regierung das
wäre jede regierung so gegangen das hat
was mit entscheidungen oder nicht
entscheidungen der vergangenheit zu tun
vor allem aber mit gedrosselten
gaslieferungen aus russland die nur der
verträge aber eben auch nicht mehr
erfüllen nein dass die dass die preise
steigen liegt nicht in ihrer
verantwortung aber das ist keine
schnelle keine schnell wirksame
reaktionen gibt das liegt in ihrer
verantwortung
ja
einen heizkostenzuschuss ist gut ein
heizkostenzuschuss ist gut aber er
reicht nicht er ist führt zu wenige zu
wenig energiepreise sind mittlerweile
eine echte soziale frage
krankenpfleger polizistin handwerker all
diejenigen die unser land am laufen
halten die mache mittlerweile mit einem
ziemlich klamm gefühl die heizung werner
vens kalte tage gibt wir müssen an der
zapfsäule sehr genau überlegen wie viel
liter benzin denn heute sein müssen
handwerker
bis hin zum großkonzern die unternehmen
überlegen sich gerade sehr genau ob sie
investitionen hier in deutschland machen
ob sie aufschieben fallenlassen ins
ausland verlegen all diese menschen
können nicht auf wärmeres wetter warten
die brauchen entlastung bei den preisen
und zwar jetzt und sofort liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
dazu schlagen wir einiges vor die
eeg-umlage abzuschaffen die stromsteuer
und die mehrwertsteuer auf die energie
deutlich zu senken die pendlerpauschale
auf 38 cent zu erhöhen es sind nur drei
der wichtigsten maßnahmen sie sind
übrigens auch fair und finanzierbar weil
nicht zuletzt der staat mit verdient an
den höheren energiepreisen bei der
mehrwertsteuer bei hohen co2 preisen das
ist nur fair und gerecht wenn in dieser
schwierigen lage auch in dieser sozialen
frage die bürgerinnen und bürger dann
auch wieder entlastet werden und das ist
das was wir einfordern
sie reden viel vom sofortprogramm
klimaschutz ist ja auch alles okay aber
was ist braucht noch dringlicher braucht
ist ein preise runter sofortprogramm ein
entlastungsprogramm und zwar sofort
minister das ist jedenfalls das was wir
erwarten und das ist vor allem das was
die bürgerinnen und bürger erwarten und
auch erwarten dürfen
und drittens in aller kürze unsere
starke abhängigkeit vom russischen gas
erweist sich auch als ziemliche achilles
ferse das spüren wir dieser tage
schmerzhaft wer aber aus kernenergie und
kohle aus steigt braucht auch wenn er in
erneuerbare energien stärker einsteigt
auf absehbare zeit gas und er braucht
vor allem versorgungssicherheit und sie
können jetzt zehnter debatte darüber
führen was alles hätte entschieden
werden müssen sie regieren gerade sie
müssen mit den dingen wie sie sind
umgehen und deswegen deswegen müssen wir
offenkundig
offenkundig auch ein sofortprogramm für
gas haben für mehr gaskraftwerke
verlässliche gaslieferungen mehr
strategische gasreserven für lng
terminal für flüssiggas aus dem ausland
das haben sie ja herr minister
richtigerweise gesagt ich sehe nur bei
den begriff lng terminals ihre eigene
fraktion in teilen doch schon zucken wir
sehen doch wie an den standorten den
möglichen jetzt schon die ersten grünen
bürgerinitiativen sich wieder gründen
und in bewegung setzen ich weiß nicht ob
sie ihre fraktionen und ihre partei beim
thema terminal an ihrer seite haben uns
als union haben sie dabei an ihrer seite
wir brauchen lng terminals und
flüssiggas um nicht so stark abhängig zu
sein vom
russland
kurzum liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir erwarten dass die regierung zu den
fragen unserer zeit hier im deutschen
bundestag stellung bezieht auch und
gerade zu den explodierenden
energiepreisen und
wir fordern taten wie wir sie in unserem
antrag beschreiben ankündigen und
ankündigungen und warme worte alleine
lindern die finanzielle not der
bürgerinnen und bürger der unternehmen
in deutschland nicht die brauchen ein
preis runter programm sofort
[Applaus]
also die cdu csu opposition jetzt in der
angenehmen situation zu fordern das
einfach mal entlastungen herkommen
sollen jetzt sparen hat natürlich recht
viele belastungen entstehen durch den
staat aber dieses geld ist ja eigentlich
verplant das wird sicherlich michael
show die der finanzpolitische sprecher
der spd jetzt das wort hat auch erwähnt
nicht zu ende wir leben geopolitische
konflikte die eskalieren drohen wir
erfahren auch und daraus resultierend
lieferengpässe und ein preisschock bei
fossilen energieträgern die
bundesregierung und die sie tragenden
fraktionen
arbeiten mit hochdruck und beständig
daran lösungen für all diese themen zu
formulieren wir haben einiges auf den
weg gebracht wir werden einige auf den
weg bringen wie wirkungsvoll die schnell
umsetzbar und finanzierbar sind
zum thema energie preissteigerung mit
drei anträge zweier bad boy von fdp und
linke
bemerkenswert ist aber auch ich sagte
unruhigen ist es zu sehen wie
cdu und csu in atemberaubender
geschwindigkeit
langjährigen regierungspartei zu einer
unseriösen
oppositionspartei sich entwickelt diese
anklagt zeigt dies deutlich an drei
punkten
zum einen was sie vorlägen ist ein
bauchladen alles was sie in so zugerufen
wohin letzten wochen haben sie da
reingepackt 22 einzelmaßnahmen die sich
doppeln die sich ausschließen die sogar
kontraproduktiv sind ich sagte sie
wollen einerseits bei der stromsteuer
die abzusenken und wollen auch noch der
spitzenausgleich gleichzeitig angehen
das ist obsolet wenn sie das eine tun es
sind vollkommen ein sammelsurium nicht
aufeinander abgestimmter einzigen
forderungen statt gezielter maßnahmen
die von ihnen als ehemaliger erwartet
hätte deshalb auch lehnen wir diesen
antrag ab ich darf auch zitieren aus
ihren antrag sie fordern nämlich auf die
bundesregierung im rahmen der
verfügbaren haushaltsmittel diese
forderungen umzusetzen
das ist eine interessante forderungen
sie heißt entweder sie wollen mit blick
auf die haushaltslage die forderung gar
nicht umsetzen oder sie müssen farbe
bekennen wie wollen sie denn das alles
finanzieren wollen sie höhere steuern
wollen sie neue kredite denn anders sind
ihre 22 punkte gar nicht zu finanzieren
die zeit und die welt hat das mal
ausgerechnet ich übrigens auch
40 milliarden euro würden alle maßnahmen
kosten die sie hier aufgeschrieben ohne
ein wort der gegenfinanzierung das ist
ein oppositions wolkenkuckucksheim
antrag aber keine seriöse politik die
sie hier vortragen
und in der so genannten toolbox ersparen
die sie
aufnehmen und wie sie beziehen die
toolbox eu kommission davor die
kommission insbesondere
soziale unterstützungsmaßnahmen
möglichst als pauschale zeitlich
befristete zielgerichtete entlastungen
für bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen aber
nicht maßgaben machst du mit der
gießkanne die zum teil speziell
spitzenverdiener entlasten würden wir
haben und wir werden die zielte
maßnahmen für die auf den weg bringen
die besonders unter den energiepreisen
den gaspreisen zu leiden haben das sind
kleinere und mittlere einkommen gesagt
wir tun ich sondern wir haben nichts vor
natürlich zu müssen nun mal genauer
zuhören vielleicht einmal die zeitung
lesen heizkostenzuschuss wohl geld
wohngeld dynamisierung übrigens da heute
erste lesung wohngeld dynamisierung
vorgezogene abschaffung eeg-umlage
weitere maßnahmen wie der mindestlohn
wird helfer sofort zuschlag für kinder
endlich mal eine gerechte aufteilung des
co2 preise zwischen mieter und vermieter
was mit ihnen nicht zu machen oder auch
die mindest ausbildungsvergütung bringen
wir auf den weg und zuletzt
muss man ja deutlich sagen herr sparen
das ist eine fossile inflation es sind
die fossilen energieträger wie die
preise treiben deshalb werden wir auch
mittel und langfristig dafür sorgen dass
die preise sich senken weil die
günstigsten preise erhalten wir mit den
erneuerbaren energien oder saßen die
doch sein treppenwitz der geschichte
dass sie uns jetzt auffordern wollen die
erneuerbaren energien schneller ausbauen
auszubauen sie saßen am kabinettstisch
das sagt ein herr altmaier auch mit
dabei ich kann mich erinnern dass ist
derjenige war der gebremst hat die solar
deckel drauf gelassen hat war der
windenergie getrennt hat das irgendwie
jähnigen und glaube auch dass in ihrer
dass in der csu
dass es da den bayerischen windkraft
verhinderer markus söder gibt der in
bayern verhindert dass erneuerbare
energien ausbauen da kehren sie vor
ihrer haustür wir werden als
bundesregierung die notwendigen
maßnahmen die schnell umsetzbar sind auf
den weg bringen und wir werden die
mittel und langfristigen lösungen
nämlich den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien voranbringen das tun wir
gemeinsam geschlossen in dieser neuen
koalition und darauf freue ich mich
mannes erhärten damen und herren ja und
an diesem versprechen werden die wähler
die spd und herren schrodi messen zum
beispiel die senkung der eeg umlage die
die fdp dafür mitte des jahres
durchsetzen will widerstand dagegen gibt
es allerdings auch schon nämlich bei den
grünen die umlage um einen cent
abzusenken koste rund fünf milliarden
euro sagte die klima- und
energiepolitische sprecherin der grünen
bundestagsfraktion
ingrid nestle und der nächste redner ist
jetzt zunächst der bernd schattner von
der afd
das leben wird für die menschen in
deutschland immer teurer seit monaten
sehen wir immer stärker steigende preise
bei lebensmitteln
wohnkosten und energiekosten die
aktuelle inflationsrate liegt
mittlerweile bei rund fünf prozent
im dezember hatten wir die höchste
inflation seit über 30 jahren
zusätzlich werden die sparer durch die
aktuelle niedrigzinspolitik durch die
hintertür enteignet es wird höchste zeit
dass wir unsere bürger hier spürbar
entlasten und insbesondere die
energiepreise steigen
google erregenden höhen das tägliche
leben wird für viele menschen in unserem
land bald unbezahlbar sein egal ob wir
uns die spritpreise anschauen oder die
nächste heizkostenabrechnung zur zeit
können die preise nur eine richtung
stark nach oben und sicherlich erinnern
sich noch jeder von ihnen an die aussage
unseres jetzigen kanzlers dass er nichts
zählt tanken muss und daher die preise
nicht kennt mit anderen worten der
bundeskanzler hat keine ahnung wie teuer
das leben in deutschland mittlerweile
geworden ist
aber fragen sie doch mal ihre wähler zu
hause im wahlkreis die können es ihnen
ganz genau sagen die märkte es nämlich
tägliche ihrem geldbeutel die meisten
abgeordneten hier im haus dürften die
preise vermutlich nicht kennen daher
macht sich ihre informationen heute
morgen kostete der liter super im biz in
berlin mittlerweile ein euro 85 aber
schauen wir in dem zusammenhang noch
einmal in unsere nachbarländer wie diese
mit dem aktuellen problem umgehen polen
hat aktuell die mehrwertsteuer auf
kraftstoffe von 23 8 prozent gesenkt und
damit ist der liter sprit in polen
mittlerweile um rund 60 cent billiger
als in deutschland
und während an der grenze zu polen die
tankstellen auf deutscher seite
verweisen und die pächter kurz vor dem
ruin stehen boomt der tanktourismus
nachholen und nicht nur bei steuern und
abgaben sind wir europaweit
spitzenreiter auch unsere
kraftstoffpreise gehören mittlerweile zu
den höchsten in der jungen in meiner
anfrage an das bundesfinanzministerium
auf eine senkung der mehrwertsteuer bzw
energie steuern auf kraftstoffe in
deutschland möglich wäre bekam ich
folgende antwort die umsatz und die
energie steuer werden erhoben um die
finanzierung der staatlichen aufgaben zu
sichern eine senkung dieser steuern
würde ihre lenkungswirkung schmälern und
fortschritte bei der bekämpfung des
klimawandels verlangsamen offensichtlich
ist auch hier mittlerweile die einzige
liberale fdp vor dem zeitgeist des
grünen klima waren es komplett
eingebrochen
unser politischer grundsatz
ist die rettung des deutschen
steuerzahlers und eben nicht die des
weltklimas aktuell sind mittlerweile 60
prozent des spritpreises auch steuern
und abgaben an den fiskus zurückzuführen
und deswegen sind unsere forderungen
nach einer befristeten absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer sowie die abschaffung der
co2 steuer ökonomisch und
gesellschaftlich das gebot der stunde
ich kann natürlich nachvollziehen dass
ihre links grün gelbe koalition
überhaupt kein interesse an einer lösung
der hier debattierten probleme hat
schließlich führen diese horrenden
preise zu sprudelnden steuereinnahmen an
der zapfsäule die hier vorgestellten
vorschläge der union zählen eigentlich
in die richtige richtung leider geben
sie aber auch der weg des klima
aktivismus in ihren forderungen mit und
deshalb werden wir diesen antrag uns
enthalten müssten dahingegen ist unser
vorgestellte antrag zur senkung der
mehrwertsteuer in antrag zur entlastung
der unternehmen arbeitnehmer und
familien in deutschland gleichermaßen
und beide immer stärker werdenden
staatlichen gängelung der menschen in
unserem land sind wir uns als
alternative für deutschland nicht nur
den schutz der bürger irgendeinen grünen
klima waren der bundesregierung
verpflichtet sondern ebenso dem schutz
der grundrechte und genau aus diesem
grund werden wir auch am fünften mehr
hat seinen deutschlandweiten aktionstag
gegen eine staatlich verordnete ihm
pflichtveranstaltung und doch mal zurück
zum antrag stimmen sie unserem antrag zu
sie würden damit insbesondere den
ländlichen raum unterstützen die
wirtschaft ankurbeln und das jeden eines
jeden einzelnen in deutschland leichter
machen vielen dank
der bundestag debattiert über massnahmen
gegen zu hohe energiepreise und die
nächste rednerin hatte ich vorhin schon
angesprochen ingrid nestle sprecherin
für klimaschutz und energie sie hat
gesagt
dass die eeg-umlage streichung der
völlig falsche weg sei das koste 5
milliarden euro die hälfte würde schon
reichen um den menschen die wirklich
moment probleme hätten mit den hohen
energiepreisen zu helfen distler
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen herrscher sie
haben es geschafft in einer rede auf die
energiewende zu kämpfen die unsere
unabhängigkeit von den fossilen
reduzieren würde und mit krokodilstränen
dach zu beweinen was die abhängigkeit
der vorziehen verfolgen hat nämlich die
hohen energiepreise
das ist bemerkenswert aber nicht seriös
sagen
und damit zu ihrem antrag werte
kolleginnen und kollegen der cdu sie
sind mutig das muss man ihnen lassen sie
führen unter punkt 2 ganz korrekt auf
was wir brauchen um uns zu lösen aus
dieser abhängigkeit von infizieren um zu
verhindern die ursachen die gerade die
preissteigerung verursachen zwei
beispiele effizienz steigern nur dass
sie in ihrer regierungszeit diesen punkt
der nicht nur unzureichend
vorangetrieben haben sondern sogar zum
teil aktiv hinter tina ein beispiel nur
nehmen wir die effizienz bei autos sie
haben der eu aktiv verhindert dass wir
anspruchsvolle effizienzvorgaben haben
und beim effizienzlabel für autos sind
die autos besser die schwerer sind dafür
haben sie sich eingesetzt dass es keinen
fortschritt bei der effizienz
ähnlich ist es unabhängigkeit von
fossilen der erneuerbaren eingebrochen
die sanierung ist nicht vorangekommen
von daher ja es ist nötig dass sie das
benennen und natürlich ja brauchen wir
kurzfristig maßnahmen um mit den
energiepreisen um auf den hohen
energiepreise zu reduzieren aber das
jetzt aus allen rohren gleichzeitigen
der subventions kanone schießen wollen 9
milliarden umsatzsteuer 7 milliarden
stromsteuer zehn milliarden kalte
progression
und zielgenauigkeit schießen wollen das
ist natürlich nicht die lösung und
deshalb
deshalb kann man sagen sie haben sich
sehr schnell und sehr umfassend in ihrer
rolle als opposition eingefunden aber
aus den genannten gründen können wir den
antrag leider nicht annehmen
und zugleich wir haben schon mehrere
maßnahmen auf den weg gebracht und
arbeiten weiteres hat mein kollege
gerade ausgeführt ich glaube dass gleich
meinen letzten drei sekunden nicht denn
zugleich
hören sie mir einmal ganz kurz noch
fertig zu hören zugleich möchte ich ihr
angebot annehmen ja ich freue mich dass
sie erkannt haben dass wir jetzt
energieeffizienz brauchen das wir
unabhängigkeit von den fossilen brauchen
und lassen sie uns ja gerne gemeinsam
nach lösungen suchen denn die
unternehmen und die menschen im land
brauchen zwei allein sie brauchen
zielgerichtete unterstützung
zielgerichtete unterstützung da wo es am
meisten schmerzt kurzfristig weil wir in
der patsche sitzen wegen dem was
unterblieben ist und wir brauchen aber
auch langfristige planungssicherheit und
da hilft es bestimmt wenn wir einen
breiten konsens hinbekommen der uns aus
der sorgenden abhängigkeit von den
fossilen energien lösen kann herzlichen
dank
für eine zwischenfrage stellen hab ich
habe nur zwei minuten
nächste rednerin für die fraktion die
linke amira mohammed ali
sie ist die fraktionsvorsitzende und die
linken fordern eine sofortige
einmalzahlung von 200 euro an alle
menschen deren einkommen unter der
armutsschwelle liegt
hier geht der frau präsidentin
kolleginnen kollegen die gestiegene
energiekosten sind ein riesenproblem im
schnitt sind sie im laufe des letzten
jahres bereits kosten und circa 50
prozent bei sprit um 38 bei strom um 9
prozent angestiegen das kann so wirklich
weiter
denn was das konkret bedeutet das möchte
ich jetzt mal ein beispiel festmachen
eine frisörin in brandenburg die
verdient 1300 euro netto im monat oder
andere sich nicht vorstellen können dass
es so wenig ist aber das ist bittere
realität für millionen arbeitnehmer auch
in vollzeit auch in ausbildungsberufen
viele verdienen sogar weniger sie wohnt
in einer zweizimmerwohnung und pendelt
jeden morgen 25 kilometer mit dem auto
zur arbeit denn da fährt kein bus auch
das ist realität für millionen menschen
unserem land dieser weg kostet sie heute
etwa 50 euro mehr im monat als vor einem
jahr für die warme wohnung sind es
mindestens 70 euro für strom kommen noch
mal zehn euro mehr dazu macht zusammen
130 euro monatliche mehrbelastung das
sind zehn prozent des monatsmittels und
was das konkret bedeutet heißt dass
viele menschen sich ernsthaft fragen
müssen heizen oder essen und das ist
doch wirklich ein skandal
und was tut jetzt die bundesregierung
gehen wir die maßnahmen durch die wollen
den menschen die wohngeldberechtigt sind
135 euro heizkostenzuschuss seien nicht
pro monat nein nur einmal das reicht
nicht aus und wissen sie was die
friseurin die bekommt davon gar nichts
weil sie halten sich fest dafür zu viel
verdient
richtig wäre stattdessen was wir fordern
dass der co2 preis auch in der tiefe
mieterinnen und mieter sofort entfällt
sie wollen auch verdient die eeg-umlage
nächstes jahr streichen und gut aber die
not die herrscht doch jetzt dass es viel
zu spät wir fordern daher die
mehrwertsteuer energie zu senken von 19
auf 7 prozent das bringt bares geld für
die bürgerinnen und bürger und zwar
zeigte
christian linder hat außerdem gesagt die
pendlerpauschale die solle erhöht werden
da verrate ich ihnen jetzt mal was auch
davon hat die friseurin aus brandenburg
gar nichts
geringes einkommen zahlt sie kaum
steuern sie kann heute nicht mein die
pendlerpauschale voll ausnutzen
stattdessen wäre es richtig was wir
fordern im mobilitäts geld auszuzahlen
das wird direkt ausgezahlt davon
profitieren alle pendlerinnen und
pendler dass wir richtig geschnitten
kolleginnen und kollegen neben diesen
effektiven sofortmaßnahmen braucht es
natürlich auch langfristige konzepte zum
beispiel die einführung einer
funktionierenden staatlichen
preisaufsicht energie außerdem muss der
strompreis von spekulationen an der
börse endlich in coppito
und spies dass einige auch hier im hause
die hohen energiekosten befürworten weil
sie meinen dass leute dann weniger auto
fahren weil sie meinen dass das den
klimaschutz voran berichtet aber das ist
ein irrtum denn die friseurinnen
brandenburg hat wie viele andere keine
alternative zum auto und was die hohen
spritkosten bewirken ja das kann man
aktuell an der deutsch polnischen grenze
bestaunen der tanktourismus punkt und
übrigens nicht nur bei den bürgerinnen
und bürgern führen die hohen
energiekosten zu löcher im portemonnaie
auch die klammen kommunen leiden die
heute kaum noch wissen wie die
bibliothek oder schwimmbad offen halten
sollen und die preissenkung im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr die für
die verkehrswende wichtig werden die
rücken so in immer weitere ferne ist der
falsche weg und außerdem
und außerdem sehen wir dass die
ewiggestrigen von rechts die preis
explosion ausnutzen um den dringend
notwendigen klimaschutz pauschal zu
diskreditieren
ein grund mehr den steigenden
verbraucherpreisen sofort ein heizung
bieten kolleginnen kollegen
zusammenfassend für uns als linke ist
klar das leben das muss bezahlbar sein
und zwar für alle
damen und herren wir haben ja mehrfach
schon jetzt den
bundeswirtschaftsminister auf der
regierungsbank gesehen wenn ich so
richtig drüber schauen wird er in dieser
debatte hier jedenfalls nicht das wort
ergreifen
ganz anders ist das mit michael kruse
denen die hier schon erkennen können er
ist der energiepolitische sprecher der
fdp fraktion und hat jetzt als nächster
das wort in der debatte über die
energiepreise im deutschen bundestag
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt
besondere lieber kollege sparen ich
wusste immer dass wir beide in einer
unterschiedlichen
realität leben dass wir uns hier
ausgerechnet von der person die
eineinhalb jahre
alles im bereich der korona politik an
diesem hause hier vorbei gewunken hat
anhören müssen wir müssten jetzt die
relevanten debatten ins parlament und
das ein treppenwitz des jahres herr
kollege sparen
und bei ihrem antrag geht es ja gerade
weiter ich hab dem mit einer gewissen
verwunderung gelesen denn eigentlich
handelt es sich hierbei um die
mängelliste der unions energiepolitik
meine damen und herren wir kehren jetzt
hinter ihrer arbeit hin und her weil sie
jahrelang hier oben auf diesem weg
überhaupt nichts auf die kette kriegt
haben sie schreiben und das ja das
spannende wo sind sie eigentlich ganz
besonders unscharf sie schreiben den
schaden tragen nun die endkunden den
erheblich teurere grundversorgung story
verfallen ja aber die verantwortung
lieber kollege sparen die trägt ihre
bundesregierung die letzte
bundesregierung die sich insbesondere im
bereich bereich der regulierung der
gasmärkte überhaupt nichts auf die kette
gebracht hat wir brauchen in diesem
bereich eine nachtwächterstaat der
nachtwächter der hatte bisher ein
schwarzes parteibuch nur leider hat der
nachtwächter geschlafen und wenn der
nachtwächter im nachtwächterstaat
schläft dann wird es besonders bitter
das liegt in ihrer verantwortung wir
räumen jetzt auf hinter ihrer politik
meiner lieben kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union
und jetzt jetzt wirds ganz besonders
spannend der erste satz ihres antrags
der eine inhaltlich forderung auf macht
lautet ja gleich wir kassieren dem rest
des antrags nämlich ihre haushälter
waren zumindest so wachsam herzlichen
dank an die kolleginnen und kollegen ein
haushaltsvorbehalt hier rein zu
schreiben und ich bin sehr gespannt ob
von ihnen hier gleich noch jemand in die
rede geht und von ihren haushältern und
uns erklärt wo denn das geld liegt was
sie hier alles verausgaben wollen ich
finde es ganz spannend ich komme gleich
darauf zurück ich finde es ja ganz
spannend wie ihr parlaments verständnis
ist sie haben von uns parlamentsdebatte
eingefordert und die führen wir gerne
wie sie sehen nur eins ist neu für mich
die regierung
verständigt sich darauf die eeg-umlage
abzuschaffen die regierung ist bereit
die eeg-umlage abschaffung sogar
vorzuziehen aufgrund der ernsten lage in
der wir sind und jetzt kommen sie mit
einem oppositionsantrag und fordernd
genau das munter von uns ein meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren sie von der
union sie müssen in der opposition
wirklich noch sehr viel lernen
sie haben ja eine ganze ganze ein
bisschen überspringe ich jetzt die
kollegen die geschätzten kollegen aus
der ampel sind ja darauf eingegangen
dass sehr viele forderungen sich teils
widersprechen manche halten wir im
grundsatz auch für richtig natürlich
wäre es gut die stromsteuer bis hin zu
senken aber sie müssen dann eben auch
einen vorschlag machen wir kommen wir in
die haushaltsberatungen die da der mit
einem guten vorschlag um die ecke kommt
kann ja dann auch für sich in anspruch
nehmen eine maßnahme auch durchzusetzen
was mich ganz besonders verwundert hat
ist dass sie die tür richtung
atomenergie auf lassen in ihrem antrag
denn genau diese form von politik ist es
ja die uns ja erst in diesen hohen preis
lage geführt hat ihre energiepolitik und
die abhängigkeit von den fossilen hat
dazu geführt dass wir in dieser
dramatischen lage sind ich kann ihnen
von der union nur sehr raten nur weil
sie herrn märz wieder zum vorsitzenden
gewählt haben müssen sie in der
energiepolitik nicht auch in die 90er
jahre zurück liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir werden mit dieser ampel koalition
das zeitalter der erneuerbaren
beschreiten wir werden kabel liegt
verhindern und wir werden das erreichen
weil wir die probleme beim planungsrecht
ich sie nicht haben ausräumen können nun
endlich beheben damit wir voran kommt
und damit die preise in diesem land
sinken und zwar dauerhaft und zwar von
dem niveau was sie und eingebrockt haben
herzlichen dank
michael kothe mit teilweise sehr
persönlichen
angriffen die ja vielleicht jetzt
mathias middelberg stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende excel access to
kontern kann wo soll das geld herkommen
die pendlerpauschale zum beispiel soll
auf 38 cent erhöht werden pro kilometer
vielleicht kann der mittelberg das ja
aufklären
kruse die bemerken will ich mir doch
erlauben sie sollten sich ihre rede
vielleicht nachher nochmal ein video
ansehen ich fand ehrlich dass das jetzt
richtig eine arrogante rede war das sage
ich ihnen ganz ehrlich
es war es war ausgesprochen
überheblich gegenüber der opposition und
es war ohne irgend einen konkreten
vorschlag wie sie der situation über die
wir heute hier sprechen begegnen ich
habe nicht einen einzigen konkreten
beitrag von ihnen dazu vernommen
wird die fdp ist ja in den wahlkampf
gegangen und hat versprochen es gibt
keine steuererhöhungen gibt keine
mehrbelastung und wenn sie sich die
situation jetzt ansehen sind sie voll in
diesem szenario drin sie haben massive
steuererhöhungen und zwar einfach de
facto über die kalte progression
sie haben massive mehrbelastungen für
die breite der bürger über massiv
gestiegene energiepreise da können sie
doch nicht einfach darüber hinweggehen
sie haben die stärkste inflation seit 30
jahren das ist hier angesprochen worden
mit über 5 prozent preissteigerung im
letzten dezember und 4,9 in diesem
januar und da leisten sie hier keinen
konkreten beitrag das was sie bisher in
die wege geleitet haben ist das thema
heizkostenzuschuss und das war's und
über den abbau der eeg-umlage und wann
sie es machen wollen darüber diskutiert
diese regierung und auch bei der
pendlerpauschale sind sich uneins sie
haben überhaupt nichts im portfolio das
ist die wahrheit kein einziger konkreter
vorschlag
ich finde dass und das sage ich ihnen
ganz offen super arrogant gegenüber den
menschen die jetzt für jede tankfüllung
20 30 euro mehr zahlen die pendler sind
und am ende des monats 23 und 400 euro
möglicherweise mehr für ihren berufsweg
hinlegen müssen gegenüber den
familienvätern gegenüber
alleinerziehenden die demnächst
heizkosten zu tragen haben die 1000 und
weit noch darüber hinaus euro mehrkosten
im jahr betragen werden da müssen sie
dem einen oder anderen letzte hilfe
gewähren da hilft nicht der hinweis auf
den energieumbau dir her richtig ist
aber der technische umbau der findet
jetzt im laufe der jahre statt wir
müssen aber jetzt den menschen helfen
die unter diesen massiven
preissteigerungen leiden wir haben vier
prozent inflation wahrscheinlich auch in
diesem jahr das frisst jede lohnerhöhung
absehbar auf gleichzeitig wandern die
leute die arbeitnehmer die die arbeiten
im steuertarif weiter nach oben und das
ist die steuererhöhungen von der sie
versprochen haben dass die nicht käme so
und wenn du jetzt aber doch gekommen ist
dann ist doch die anforderungen an sie
gerade an einem fdp finanzminister was
macht er denn jetzt um die belastung der
leute auszugleichen danach fragen doch
die menschen in diesem land sie haben
doch den tarif auf rädern gepredigt
jetzt hören wir nichts mehr davon jetzt
haben wir gehört dass herr dürr ihr
fraktionsvorsitzender in der
wirtschaftswoche im januar angekündigt
hat der progression bericht solle jetzt
in kürze vorgelegt werden normalerweise
mit einem herbst vorgelegt in kürze soll
er jetzt vorgelegt werden vorwärts dann
sagt uns der finanzminister von diesem
platz er wird jetzt doch im herbst
vorgelegt da sage ich ihnen herr lindner
hat hier mehrfach gesessen hat gesagt er
wäre ermöglichung minister jetzt
erwarten wir von ihm aber auch dass man
bei dem thema entlastung der bürger
möglichkeiten schafft
so und wenn sie dann entlasten thema
heizkostenzuschuss dann sage ich ihnen
sie müssen auch gerecht entlassen sie
müssen nicht nur an die denken die
empfänger von sozialleistungen sind
sondern sie müssen vor allen dingen an
die denken die in diesem land auch
arbeiten jeden tag zur arbeit fahren die
lange wege haben auch die müssen sie
entlasten deswegen kommen sie jedenfalls
vorübergehend an einem thema wie
pendlerpauschale nicht vorbei denn nicht
jeder hat die möglichkeit auf den öpnv
ort zu wechseln und sie lassen die
menschen auf dem lande im ländlichen
raum mit ihrer politik schlichtweg im
stich wie sind mit ihrer politik
verlassen
so und letzter punkt weil sie das immer
problematisieren hier das sei nicht
durchgerechnet das was wir vorgelegt
haben ist durchaus durchgerechnet die
sachen auch ganz deutlich sie haben
massive mehreinnahmen ich will nur drei
punkte nennen co2 emissionshandel
europäisch und auch national das sind
erhebliche milliarden die sie zusätzlich
an einnahmen haben werden sie werden
mehr einnahmen haben aus der lohnsteuer
und sie haben jetzt schon reichlich mehr
einnahmen aus der umsatzsteuer im
zweijahresvergleich dezember letztes
jahr zu zwei jahren vorher 2009/10
gerechnet über 30 prozent steigerung
alleine bei der umsatzsteuer bei diesem
thema heute geht es nicht darum dass wir
den leuten zusätzlich irgendwas
versprechen oder unsolide irgendwas zu
sagen würden sondern es geht schlichtweg
darum dass sie den menschen das
zurückgeben müssen sie ihn über abgaben
und steuern aus der tasche gezogen haben
das ist die wahrheit
iris redner in der debatte ist der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der spd
bernd westphal weil ich vorhin dem
minister ansprache ist natürlich in der
tat so dass der wirtschaftsminister ihr
nicht das wort ergreift da sind ja auch
drei anträge der oppositionsfraktionen
das ist so üblich dass man darüber dann
nicht auch als minister ans pult tritt
aber warum eigentlich nicht warum kann
man das nicht ändern und den bürgern
heute mal sagen wo man vorhat
energiepreise zu entlassen das wäre doch
mal ein guter ansatz sein westphal jetzt
sagen das soziale gewissen der cdu csu
fraktion das habe ich in den letzten
jahren nicht erkennen wenn weder bei
tarifbindung peter beim mindestlohn noch
bei entlassung von arbeitnehmerinnen
teilnehmer von daher ist das schon ein
stück weit schräg was sie hier
vorgetragen haben zum thema
selbstverständlich braucht es nicht den
antrag der cdu csu um sich mit den
wichtigen themen dieses landes zu
beschäftigen
das sind natürlich die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung das ist eine inflation die
getrieben ist durch energiepreise das
ist ein riesen transformationsprozess
unseres wirtschaftsstandorts deutschland
und deshalb ist es natürlich richtig
dass diese bundesregierung und das
zeichnet sich schon ab in den
koalitionsvertrag vom letzten herbst
genau mit der frage auseinandersetzt wie
kann diese gesellschaft wie kann dieser
wirtschaftsstandort aus den fossilen
aussteigen und einen weg in das
erneuerbare zeitalter aufträgen und
deshalb ist es wichtig die erneuerbaren
energien auszubauen und zwar sage ich
dass deswegen weil ich die bremser in
ihrer fraktion noch live erlebt haben
bei den verhandlungen wenn es darum ging
bei wind abständen haben sie geblockt
beim ausbau der photovoltaik am segel
block mit einem deckel wollten sie den
versehen das waren die debatten die wir
geführt haben und deshalb ist es richtig
dass wir jetzt eine andere regierung
hören
und das hier
und das ja sie müssen schon zu hören und
dass wir nichts machen stimmt nicht
gerade das was wir mit ihnen diskutiert
haben bei dem co2 preis bei der
entlastung der mieterinnen und mieter
war es ihre fraktion die ist behindert
hat dass wir die kosten aufteilen und
das werden wir jetzt teilen diesen
fehler sie wollten dass alles den
mieterinnen und mieter auf lassen die
gar keine chance haben dass wir zu
sorgen dass eine andere heizung im
keller existieren
und natürlich muss man gucken dass es
auch seriös finanziert werden können ich
finde das muss auch dazu gehören dass
man den haushalt spieler nimmt und in
der verteilungsfrage dass auch gezielt
dort ansetzen wo es notwendig ist und
deshalb machen wir das genauso mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss das sind nämlich
genau diejenigen mit geringen einkommen
die wir jetzt entlasten wollen und
deshalb ist das ziel gerichtet ihre
heizung ich weiß nicht wie die aussieht
der mittelberg und deshalb ist es glaube
ich angebracht dass in der sozialen
flankierung auch sozialgericht zu machen
der zweite punkt die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage haben wir lange darüber
diskutieren ich kann mich noch an den
button im wirtschaftsausschuss erinnern
in der letzten legislaturperiode wir
haben peter altmaier oft aufgefordert zu
sagen lasst uns das steuern abgaben
umlagen system gerade im energiebereich
anfassen das ist nicht mehr was sich zu
der heutigen zeit und genau diese dinge
werden wir jetzt mit der abschaffung der
eeg-umlage im ersten schritt anfang und
natürlich brauchen wir in einem
zeitalter
erneuerbaren die immer stärker im system
eine bedeutung haben auch ein anderer
bepreisung da gehört strommarkt design
und andere dinge mit dazu und deshalb
ist es richtig mit der abschaffung der
eeg-umlage jetzt im sommer das richtige
zeichen zu setzen und zwar nicht nur für
die privaten haushalte sondern natürlich
auch wieder energieintensiven
unternehmen die hier in der
internationalen wettbewerbsfähigkeit
auch erhalten müssen weitere maßnahmen
werden wir ja auf den weg bringen und
gerade der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wird dazu führen dass wir die
abhängigkeit von fossilen und teuren
energien dementsprechend reduzieren und
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir zum
beispiel auch den wasserstoff hochlauf
organisieren genau diese
infrastrukturmaßnahmen begleiten eine
wasserstoffwirtschaft die dazu führt
dass wir eben eine unabhängigkeit von
fossilen energien kriegen die jetzt
preistreiber sind das ist jedenfalls das
ziel dieser regierung und zum schluss
möchte ich möchte ich noch eins erwähnen
wir haben in der erholung der
volkswirtschaft zumindest was jetzt auch
nach der pandemie ist einiges auf den
weg zu bringen und ich will noch mal
daran erinnern dass wir jetzt in einer
guten phase sind der pandemie die sich
sicherlich positiv entwickeln wird in
den nächsten wochen und wir müssen alles
dafür tun dass wir nicht in eine
situation im herbst hineinstolpern die
gerade was arbeitsplätze angeht was
wirtschaftliche entwicklung angeht vor
dem gleichen dilemma stehen und deshalb
kann ich nur dazu aufrufen lassen sie
sich impfen lassen sie sich informieren
machen sie alles dafür dass wir mit der
impfkampagne weiterkommen und dann wird
auch das was frank walter steinmeier am
sonntag nochmal erwähnt hat
unterstrichen diese transformation die
wir vor uns haben die wird nur gelingen
wenn möglichst alle davon profitieren
und daran arbeitet diese ampelkoalition
herzlichen dank sagte
wo die bürger entlastet werden können
also das was der minister hier
vielleicht auch hätte machen können in
der tat die afg hat einen eigenen antrag
in dem fordert sie drei punkte einmal
absenkung der mehrwertsteuer für ein
halbes jahr des weiteren soll das
brennstoff emissionshandel gesetz außer
kraft gesetzt werden und dann fordert
die fdp von der bundesregierung dass die
preisauszeichnung an tankstellen nur
einmal täglich um 12 uhr vorgenommen
werden darf jörg spaniel für die afd er
ist der verkehrspolitische sprecher
wir haben rekordpreise für kraftstoffe
und eine energie preisbedingte inflation
von offiziell über fünf prozent aber das
sind alles ja keine naturereignisse das
ist das ergebnis einer politik die nicht
in der lage ist die folgen des eigenen
handelns abzuschätzen und da muss ich
jetzt mal in die union gucken das was
wir hier sehen das ist doch nichts
anderes als die von ihnen verursachte
situation durch ihre eigenen gesetze
haben sie in den letzten jahren ja diese
situation geschaffen und wir haben vor
genau dieser preissteigerung von
kraftstoffen energiepreisen in diesem
plenum hier permanent gewarnt wie haben
sie darauf aufmerksam gemacht und jetzt
haben sie das ergebnis ihrer politik der
letzten jahre aber ich will mal ganz
konkret auf ihren antrag eingehen fast
alles habe ich ja schon gesagt was sie
darin beklagen ist ausschließlich durch
sie und ihre gesetze verursacht auch die
gesetze der spd natürlich und mir ist
aufgefallen dass wesentliche teile ihres
antrags den haben sie so ein bisschen
unseren afd anträgen der letzten
legislatur so ein bisschen konkret haben
wir bereits im dezember ja eine erhöhung
der kilometerpauschale
gefordert und sie haben wir sogar
unseren zahlen werden von 38 cent pro
kilometer übernommen also vielen dank
dafür dass sie dass sie auch die
eindringen und verstanden haben in der
gleichen debatte habe ich auch erstmalig
auf die unverschämte co2 besteuerung der
co2 freien kraftstoff anteile bin ich
hier auch eingegangen und auch das finde
ich in ihrem antrag wieder finde ich
toll dass sie unsere sachen so
aufgreifen aber
gut ihr sammelsurium an punkten bleibt
stückwerk in der jetzigen ja das weiß
ich aber es bleibt trotzdem sei in der
jetzigen situation hilft es jedenfalls
nicht und das muss ich ihnen jetzt mal
sagen mit schaufenster anträgen die
aufgebrachte bevölkerung etwas zu
beruhigen was die bürger in diesem land
brauchen ist eine fundamentale umkehr
von einer durch und durch ideologisch
verblendeten wünsch dir was politik
co2 reduktion um jeden preis co2
reduktion um jeden preis ist für viele
und unserem land unbezahlbar und die
umverteilungs maßnahmen die sowohl von
der eu aus ihrem werkzeugkasten
aufgeführt werden als auch die ansätze
der linken sind planwirtschaft und das
hat noch nie funktioniert
und wenn sie liebe kollegen von der
union wenn sie eine tatsächliche
entlastung der bürger in diesem land
wollen sind wir auch gerne bereit mit
ihnen gemeinsam initiativen hier in
diesem parlament einzubringen aber ich
glaube die zusammenarbeit mit uns die
haben sie sich ja selber verboten herr
kollege wirken sie denn eine
zwischenfrage auf der union klar
verständlich
na ja spanier ja wir arbeiten nicht mit
ihnen zusammen weil wir in einem punkt
fundamental anderer meinung sind und
dass du dich in einer frage formulieren
glauben sie wirklich die politik der
bisherigen bundesregierung ist dafür
verantwortlich dass überall in der welt
die energiepreise insbesondere die
fossilen energiepreise und wieso ist die
bundesregierung als die bisherige
bundesregierung schuld daran dass
russland jetzt nur das gas liefert das
sie vertraglich zugesagt hat und nicht
wie in den vergangenen jahren mehr warum
ist das schulter bundesregierung und
nicht ein weltweites phänomen
vielen dank da würde ich gerne darauf
eingehen zunächst auf die energiepolitik
und der technik die versorgung mit
russischem gas es ist natürlich richtig
dass einerseits weltmarktpreise gibt
aber andererseits und das muss ich jetzt
ja auch mal hier sagen andererseits ist
es ja so dass nord stream 2 eine
gasversorgung für deutschland sicher
stellt und wie er das sind wir ja auch
immer der meinung dass wir diese
gasversorgung brauchen und wir müssen
hier an dieser stelle auch mal klar
sagen wenn die russen und gas liefern zu
vereinbarten konditionen da gibt es da
doch überhaupt nichts dran zu
kritisieren und jetzt komme ich aber
noch mal auf die
energiepreissteigerungen die sie
ansprechen es ist doch schon
verwunderlich wenn sie genau hingucken
wie die kraftstoffpreise nur die reden
wir hier konkret die rohölpreise in der
welt die waren schon höher als jetzt
wesentlich höher aber die
kraftstoffpreise in diesem land die
waren noch nie höher als jetzt und das
liegt eben ganz wesentlich an der von
ihnen herbeigeführten co2 steuer doch da
brauchen sie nicht im kopf steht und da
können sie nach guten da gibt es jede
menge statistiken noch nie waren die
kraftstoffpreise höher obwohl wir schon
höhere rohölpreise am weltmarkt hatten
dh diese argumentation diese
argumentation dass die weltmarktpreise
bei uns das hier diktieren die ist
einfach nicht richtig und das kann jeder
nachvollziehen der im internet google
ja wenn sie mehr kommentierungen geben
wollen dann müssen wir das leider über
eine zwischenfrage machen aber so nicht
es ist niemandem damit geholfen wenn wir
hier in deutschland versuchen die welt
zu retten und uns dabei selbst ruinieren
und deshalb können wir auch ihren antrag
in der jetzigen form so leider nicht
zustimmen bitte ich um verständnis aber
wie gesagt das angebot steht kommen wir
doch einfach mal zusammen und machen
eine vernünftige politik für die
menschen in diesem land damit die
menschen sich in diesem land das leben
wieder leisten können vielen dank
[Applaus]
der bundestag debattiert über drei
anträge der drei oppositionsfraktionen
es geht um die energiepreise und der
nächste redner kommt von den
bündnisgrünen andreas dresch
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
millionen menschen in deutschland haben
gerade angst vor der nächsten
stromrechnung sie haben angst vor der
nächsten gasrechnungen und diese
menschen brauchen unterstützung weil die
fossilen energien gerade massiv die
preise nach oben treiben das was sie
vorgelegt haben liebe union ist leider
das exakte gegenteil keinerlei gezielte
maßnahmen nichts dergleichen und
gleichzeitig viele viele teure
steuergeschenke
die haben mit nichts mit
haushaltsdisziplin die haben nichts mit
solider haushaltsführung zu tun und das
ist das einzige was ich hier einbringen
können wissen sie ich mach mal zwei
beispiele ich mache mir zwei beispiele
wissen sie was es kostet die
umsatzsteuer auf strom und gas zu senken
für die zwei jahre die sie vorschlagen
18 milliarden euro das ist das was sie
da rein geschrieben haben dass es nicht
dass es tatsächlich nicht zu finanzieren
das treibt gleichzeitig die fossile
inflation das ist das was er damit
bezwecken und vor allem ist kommt bei
den leuten nicht an das ist doch völlig
klar und wenn dann der cdu-vorsitzende
noch zusätzlich sagte wir müssen die
spritsteuer senken glauben sie dass
kommt eins zu eins an der tankstelle an
nichts wird der gleichen passieren was
passiert ist dass die schecks ausstellen
können an gazprom an exxon mobile das
ist eine politik einer fossilen
inflation mit der gießkanne die es mit
uns nicht geben petric es gibt eine
zwischenfrage wunsch aus der aktion
möchten sie den demnach
zweites beispiel die pendlerpauschale
kostet wieder milliarden euro nutzt als
steuerliche abschreibung gerade denen
mit den großen einkommen und das
wichtigste weil sie sagen akute
unterstützung akut ist das nicht es wird
dann relevant wenn die steuererklärung
im nächsten jahr dann kommt das ist
keine akute unterstützung deswegen wird
auch hier ein muss nur deutlich
hemmungslos milliarden aus dem fenster
schmeißen und zwar so dass vor allem die
mit den meisten geld profitieren und
gleichzeitig die mineralöl- konzerne
dass das muss man so sagen ist keine
sinnvolle politik und genau deswegen
werden wir das so nicht mitmachen
stattdessen stattdessen und das muss man
sagen geht es um gezielte maßnahmen das
ist das was jetzt ist die finanzierbar
und umsetzbar sind der
heizkostenzuschuss erstens dann sofort
zuschlag für kinder und jugendliche und
für alle in der grundsicherung braucht
es eine schnelle einmalzahlung um
menschen aus der größten finanziellen
not zu holen das ist das was jetzt
braucht und wissen sie
und wissen sie dass wir stehen mit
diesen punkten beileibe nicht alleine in
der anfall anfang der woche hat ein
dutzend sozialverbände in der
öffentlichkeit genau das geforderte sind
rausgegangen weil not am mann und der
frau ist und wir jetzt solche lösungen
brauchen zweitens hat clemens fuß vom
ifo-institut genau das gefordert auf die
bedürftigen haushalten konzentrieren und
auch sozialtransfers anpassen die cdu
geführte regierung in nrw bringt im
bundesrat am 11 februar einen antrag an
den schließungs antrag ein und fordert
eine einmalzahlung für alle menschen in
der grundsicherung bei ihnen finde ich
nichts keinerlei gezielte maßnahmen
gezielte maßnahmen das ist das was wir
wollen sie haben keinen machbares
konzept wir sagen langfristig raus aus
der fossilen inflation raus aus den
fossilen energien rein in die
erneuerbaren und jetzt gezielt
unterstützen das ist politik sie sinn
macht und die funktioniert dankeschön
wir kommen zu einer kurzintervention des
kollegen springer von der armee fraktion
heraus es ist schade dass sie die
zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen haben
aber im grunde waren sie im grunde waren
sie ja nur konsequent ich erinnere an
die ausschusssitzung am mittwoch wo sie
gesagt haben dass sie nicht an einem
diskurs an der mit der afg interessiert
sind das ist sehr schade ich hatte
daraufhin gesagt wir sind sehr wohl mit
ein in einem diskurs mit ihnen sind auch
daran interessiert diesen diskurs zu
intensivieren unsere hand ist
ausgestreckt und wir hoffen dass wir
gemeinsam mit ihnen an einer lösung
arbeiten können für die probleme die die
inflation für viele menschen in unserem
land mit sich bringt und nun zu einer
aussage die sie getätigt haben sie
sagten auch schon in der
ausschusssitzung und heute haben sie es
noch mal wiederholt das ja
steuersenkungen aus spritpreise von den
unternehmen nicht weitergegeben werden
würden da möchte ich darauf hinweisen
dass wir das in polen während wir hier
noch debattieren und im grunde nichts
passiert niemand entlastet wird die
konservative regierung in polen
tatsächlich die steuern auf die sprit
preise gesenkt hat der sprit in polen
kostet ungefähr 60 cent weniger
inzwischen als in deutschland ich weiß
dass ich komme aus ostbrandenburg jeder
in meinem umfeld fährt inzwischen nach
polen zum tanken und die tankstellen
landschaft in ostbrandenburg geht gerade
den bach runter wenn sie also dieses
argument anführen die preise werden die
entlastungen werden nicht weitergegeben
aber polen zeigt dass das geht sind sie
bereit ihren standpunkt zu überdenken
und vielleicht doch eine senkung der
steuern auf spritpreise in betracht zu
ziehen dankeschön
herr tritt zur antwort bitte schön
jetzt geht's los ich kann das an der
stelle sehr sehr kurz machen zu einer
wehrhaften demokratie
gehört ist auch mit bestimmten
gruppierungen nicht zu sprechen dass der
grundsatz
und das bedeutet für mich dass sich mit
rechtsextremisten nicht spreche mit
rechtsextremisten nicht in einen
politischen dialog gehe und insofern ist
das auch das einzige was ich ihnen an
dieser stelle als antwort übermitteln
kann dankeschön
wenn ich dir redet punkt von der fdp
maximilian mordhorst der fdp
bundesfinanzminister hat ja sich dafür
eingesetzt die eeg-umlage im sommer
abzuschaffen das wirtschaftsministerium
prüft das im moment ob es so kommt
werden wir dann sehen
humoristischen geradezu vielleicht
aggressiven zwischenruf auch aus der
unionsfraktion wundern denn wir reden
hier über ein wahnsinnig ernstes thema
wir reden darüber ob der
oberstufenschüler der vielleicht sein
erstes auto hat und auf dem land wohnt
am ende des monats noch zur schule kommt
wir reden darüber ob der student der in
seiner ersten wohnungen wohnt mit den
stromkosten ein immer größeres problem
hat oder nicht und wir reden darüber ob
arbeitnehmer bis zum rentner in
deutschland angst haben müssen vor der
nächsten heiz und nebenkosten
abrechnungen das ist ein ernstes thema
und deswegen werden wir das haben wir
angekündigt als ampelkoalition auch
handeln dass sie so tun als würden wir
keine vorschläge machen als würden wir
den nichts entgegensetzen ist blanker
hohn wir machen vorschläge ohne ende und
deswegen ja wir können darüber jetzt
einmal kurz sprechen wir haben ja auch
ein krieg ums fremming denen sie lieber
führen als um die sache an sich die
einen sprechen von grüner inflation die
anderen von fossiler inflation man muss
sagen beides ist richtig ja es sind die
vor allem die rohstoffpreise die steigen
und die zurzeit dazu führen dass die
verbraucherpreise sich immer weiter
erhöhen und deswegen müssen wir
langfristig die energiewende so auf den
weg bekommen dass wir die unabhängigkeit
von möglichst einzelnen energieträgern
hin bekommen wir müssen bei der
übergangstechnologie gas auch davon
reden ob wir es endlich schaffen
abhängigkeiten von einzelnen staaten in
den griff zu bekommen und solche
debatten wie das lng terminal werden wir
führen sie sind sie müssen strategisch
langfristig betrachtet werden das haben
wir in der vergangenheit beispielsweise
bei den german brunsbüttel aus meiner
sicht nicht ausreichend getan herr
kollege anderen den wunsch nach einer
zwischenfrage aus der fraktion die linke
möchten sie das bitte schön
vielen dank frau präsidentin vielen dank
herr kollege dass sie die zwischenfrage
zu lassen es sind zwei fragen die erste
frage sie sprachen lng terminals zu
lassen ist ihm bekannt dass allen chicas
insbesondere aus den usa gefragt erst
mal klimaschädliches und zweitens
deutlich teurer ist als viele andere
energieform zu der die erste frage die
zweite frage ich sie sprachen gerade von
den kosten die explosion und das stimmt
und explodieren tun aber auch die
gewinne von energiekonzern vattenfall
neue meldung 4,6 milliarden gewinnen
juniper korrigiert gewinnprognose nach
oben e.on verdoppelt den gewinn auf 2,2
milliarden die energiekonzerne haben in
den letzten fünf jahren ihre gewinne
verdreifacht das sind die realität und
das ist ohne die preis explosion im
dezember/januar die noch einmal zu
weiteren gewinnsprung geführt das sind
sie deswegen nicht der meinung wie wir
das zum schutz der verbraucherinnen
verbraucher dringend eine energiepreis
aufsicht notwendig ist dass es dringend
erforderlich ist diese gewinne
einzuschränken abzukassieren damit wir
eben diese gewinne nutzen um die
energiekosten für die bevölkerung und
für die unternehmen zu senken lieber
kollege ich finde das immer wahnsinnig
interessant natürlich ist das eine
brückentechnologie und über
umweltprobleme brauchen wir gar nicht
lange zu sprechen bei russland fällt
ihnen das aber irgendwie nie ein und
dann auf der anderen seite davon zu
sprechen dass man als reaktion auf eine
wirklich problematische inflation mehr
aussichten haben möchte helikopter geld
verteilen möchte an alle möglichen
haushalte das ist nicht das gegenmittel
zur inflation solche aktionen können der
grund für inflation seien und deswegen
ist das nicht hilfreich sondern eher
problematisch auch die vorschläge die
sie in ihrem antrag unterbreiten
anderen teil ich habe gerade über
fossile oder grüne inflation gesprochen
zum anderen teil natürlich sind es die
steigenden rohstoffpreise die dazu
führen auf der anderen seite sind wir
und das müssen wir uns eingestehen sind
die anteile an den preisen beim strom
beim benzin zu einem großen teil
staatlich zu einem großen prozentsatz
besteht aus steuern und abgaben und
neben der tatsache dass wir die
eeg-umlage zeitnahe abschaffen wollen
als es die union überhaupt vorhatte mit
der tatsache dass wir den
einkommensteuertarif haben wir gestern
darüber gesprochen auf basis progression
berichts anpassen werden und mit den
zuschüssen die wir auf den weg bringen
zusätzlich müssen wir auch langfristig
wenn wir mit dem co2 preis so
weitermachen wo ich hier bin denn wir
müssen den klimawandel stoppen über das
nebeneinander von verbrauchssteuern und
co2 preis sprechen denn das
nebeneinander kann nur kurzfristig nicht
langfristig funktionieren ich bin der
überzeugung wir sollten den weg den wir
jetzt haben vernünftig beschreiten ich
finde ja interessant was sie jetzt alles
neu auf den weg bringen wollen ich habe
da so ein bisschen vielleicht auch eine
andere perspektive weil ich 25 bin und
vor menschen stehe von der union die
mich einen großen teil meines gesamten
lebens bisher fast durchgängig regiert
haben und jetzt auf einmal mit den
vorschlägen um die ecke kommen die sie
16 jahre nicht ins land gebracht haben
in unterschiedlichen konstellationen in
unterschiedlichen mehrheiten mit
unterschiedlichen prozent setzen und die
krone auf die setzen sie nicht der
kollege jolie hat zu ihren konkreten
antrag schon ausgerechnet aber die krone
setzte dem ganzen mal wieder die csu auf
wir haben das mal ausgerechnet mit dem
programm sie hatten wir auch schon ein
zwischenruf herr dobrindt mit super
schwachsinn passt zu diesem programm
deutschland in der mitte halten wir
haben das mal ausgerechnet was das so
bis 2026 kosten würde
kinderfreibetrag soll auf den
grundfreibetrag angehoben werden 8,1
milliarden generation vor 14 milliarden
anleihe mit zwei prozent garantiezins 18
milliarden mütter rente 319 milliarden
denken energiesteuern 90 haben home
office pauschale 23,8 milliarden und und
und wir sind auf eine summe am ende des
tages bis 2026 von um und bei 300
milliarden euro gekommen nebenbei noch
viele sachen die man nicht genau
beziffern kann ohne einen gegen
finanzierungsvorschlag noch besser davor
steht sogar noch ein haushaltsvorbehalt
also wie man das seriös umsetzen soll
kann ich den menschen nicht vermitteln
ich möchte es ihnen auch nicht
vermitteln denn wir werden das land und
lege machen vernünftig finanziert ich
komme zum schluss und ich bin sehr froh
dass wir das jetzt endlich nach dieser
langen zeit auf den weg bringt vielen
dank
300 milliarden meine damen und herren
das ist tatsächlich sehr viel geld man
muss sich allerdings fragen warum
deutschland die teuersten energiepreise
in europa hat vielleicht sollte man da
ansetzen der nächste redner kommt von
der cdu/csu ist sprecher für
verbraucherschutz volker ullrich der
bundestag debattiert hier über die
energiepreise und über die möglichen
senkungen anträge von cdu csu von der
linken und von der fdp liegen dem hause
vor
oder afg natürlich nicht der fdp pardon
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
die menschen erwarten ganz konkrete und
schnell wirksame lösungen in bezug auf
die steigenden gas und energiepreise
nicht wenige fragen sich was ist
bezahlbarer die warme wohnung oder der
sportunterricht für die kinder 40
prozent steigerung bei den
energiepreisen bedeutet eine neue
soziale frage aber auch für unternehmen
in der glas- keramik- und druckindustrie
ist die wettbewerbsfähigkeit längst
gefährdet ja mehr stehen arbeitsplätze
ganz konkret auf dem spiel wer jetzt bei
den hohen energiepreisen nicht sofort
handelt muss sich vorwerfen lassen die
menschen und die arbeitsplätze im stich
zu lassen wir brauchen schnell wirksame
lösungen
die bundesregierung ist nicht ursächlich
für die hohen energiepreise aber wenn
sie jetzt nicht handelt wird sie
verantwortlich werden wenn sie jetzt
nicht alles in die wege leiten und die
preise zu senken
dann ist der einkommensverlust der
mittelschicht ihre soziale kälte in
diesem land
die vorschläge die sie auf den tisch
gelegt haben reiche nicht aus
der heizkostenzuschuss ist zu wenig und
so ungenau dass klima geld das eines
tages kommen soll ist überhaupt nicht ab
ministriert weil sie nicht wissen wie
sie das geld der menschen zurückgeben
können entscheidend ist dass wir dort
ansetzen wo es sofort wirksam ist dass
die menschen sofort etwas davon haben
und spüren dass der staat sie bei den
steigen ergie kosten entlastet das ist
der kern unseres antrags was wollen wir
wir wollen die stromsteuer auf das
europäische minimum senken wir wollen
die umsatzsteuer von 19 auf sieben
prozent für energieleistungen absenkt
wir wollen die energie die abschaffung
eeg-umlage fort sie wir wollen aber auch
regulatorisch sicherstellen dass die
energieversorgungsunternehmen
diese absenkungen auch an ihre kunden
weitergeben das ist regulatorisch
möglich und das wird eine ganz klare und
deutliche entlastung bedeuten herr
kollege es gibt den wunsch nach einer
zwischenfrage aus der arktis fraktion
möchte ist zu lassen
nein
es geht aber auch um die konkreten
vertragsbeziehungen von verbrauchern zu
ihren energielieferanten
wir haben den letzten monaten
festgestellt dass viele billig
stromanbieter und billig gasanbieter von
heute auf morgen gekündigt haben dass
oftmals die post des grundversorgers im
briefkasten war und damit eine bis zu
200 prozentige erhöhung im raum stand es
muss sichergestellt werden durch
regulierung das stromanbieter nicht von
heute auf morgen kündigen können dass
eine kündigungsfrist gibt und dass
stromanbieter gerade im
niedrigpreissegment auch solide und
seriös sind dass das geschäftsmodell
trägt dass jemand der auf eine lieferung
vertraut diese lieferung auch erhält das
muss diese bundesregierung durch
regulierung sicherstellen
und
bei aller wertschätzung auch für die
lokalen stromversorger
wir müssen noch mal im kartellrecht an
die frage herangehen inwieweit an die zu
große spreizung zwischen grundtarif und
normaltarif tatsächlich angebracht ist
die menschen müssen darauf vertrauen
können dass die
senkungen im bereich der energiepreise
sofort ankommen das entbindet uns nicht
von der langfristigen pflicht die neuer
barren energien auszubauen aber jetzt
geht es um ganz konkrete entlastungen
weil die menschen angesichts steigender
energiepreise ganz konkrete
befürchtungen haben und diese müssen wir
jetzt lösen bitte stimmen sie unserem
antrag zu
[Applaus]
ihr kollege andreas mehltretter für die
spd fraktion kommt heute hier zu seiner
ersten reaktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen niemand
darf sich arm heizen müssen das steht
außer frage viele menschen können sich
aber die steigenden heizkosten nicht
leisten
dagegen müssen wir etwas tun es ist gut
dass wir uns an dieser stelle alle einig
sind wir erleben gerade eine krise der
fossilen energieerzeugung weltweit die
konjunktur zieht wieder an die
rohstoffpreise steigen
geopolitische konflikte verschärfen die
situation
wir sind das führt uns gerade diese
situation sehr deutlich vor augen immer
noch viel zu abhängig von fossilen
energieträgern
es sind diese fossilen energieträger vor
allem das erdgas die für die
sprunghaften preisanstiege
verantwortlich sind es ist eben nicht
nur klimapolitisch notwendig die
erneuerbaren schnell auszubauen es ist
auch sinnvoll für eine sichere
energieversorgung und es entlastet den
geldbeutel der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher
erneuerbare energien sind mittlerweile
günstiger als alle fossilen
energieträger von atomkraft ganz zu
schweigen wenn wir mittelfristig stabile
und günstige energiepreise haben wollen
geht das nur indem wir die erneuerbaren
energien ausbauen
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir in der
ampelkoalition auf eine schnelle
energiewende setzen erneuerbare energien
statt gas und kohle darum geht es
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich komme
aus dem bundesland in dem die csu den
ausbau der windenergie mit der 10h
regelung fast komplett gestoppt hat es
ist die blockade haltung der union die
dafür verantwortlich ist dass wir bei
den erneuerbaren noch nicht weiter sind
und dass uns die steigenden preise bei
fossilen energien jetzt vor so große
probleme stellen
auch bei einer gebäudesanierung haben
sie liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
verloren immer gebremst das ergebnis
waren zu wenig ambitionierte und
unterfinanzierte förderprogramme wir
brauchen aber eine renovierungs
offensive die heizkosten für ein gebäude
der schlechtesten effizienzklasse h sind
heute zehn mal so hoch wie die für alle
ein gebäude mit der besten
effizienzklasse a+ ohne
gebäudesanierungen zahlen die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
weiterhin zu hohe preise
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union nachdem sie also jahrelang dafür
gesorgt haben dass zu wenig passiert ist
um energie günstig und unsere gebäude
effizient zu machen kommen sie jetzt mit
so einem sammelsurium an
zusammenhangslose maßnahmen um zu
kaschieren dass sie im
wirtschaftsministerium in den letzten
jahren leider wenig auf die reihe
bekommen haben
klar kann man nach dem gießkannenprinzip
möglichst viele forderungen in einen
antrag schreiben und natürlich kann man
für 40 milliarden euro forderungen
aufstellen ohne zu sagen wo denn das
geld dafür herkommen soll man hat sich
dann aber von konstruktiver politik
komplett verabschiedet meine ist
arbeiten damen und herren
der rasante anstieg der gaspreise trifft
die haushalte am stärksten die geringe
einkommen haben und in schlecht
gedämmten wohnungen leben dort muss die
hilfe ankommen dafür müssen wir sagen
stopp gezielt zu entlasten fordern sie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von union
aber ineffiziente und teure maßnahme die
wie zb bei der pendlerpauschale auch
noch klimapolitisch falsche anreize zu
setzen es ist wirklich gut dass sie von
der regierung auf die oppositionsbank
gewechselt sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
brauchen eine perspektive für echte
unabhängigkeit von steigenden energie
rohstoffpreisen und deswegen forcieren
wir eine schnelle energiewende
vorhersehbar steigende preise für
fossile energieträger haben dabei eine
wichtige lenkungs werten gleichzeitig
haben wir auch aber immer gesagt dass es
einen schutz vor überforderung durch zu
schnell steigende preise geben muss und
die preise steigen jetzt hat einfach zu
schnell deshalb brauchen wir jetzt auch
soforthilfen es ist richtig dass wir
heute den heizkostenzuschuss für
menschen mit niedrigen einkommen auf den
weg bringen es ist richtig dass die
bundesregierung gerade prüft die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage vorzuziehen
und es ist richtig darüber zu
diskutieren wie wir plötzliche
vertragskündigungen und den rückfall in
teure grundversorgung verändern liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir brauchen
sofort hilfe und wir brauchen eine
perspektive für niedrigere heizkosten
und bezahlbare energie beides werden wir
anpacken nicht mit der gießkanne sondern
mit gezielten maßnahmen
was für untergebrachte zudem
irgendwelchen preisen zu denen ist frei
aus den oppositionsfraktionen gibt denn
die pandemie hat natürlich nicht nur
gesundheitliche auswirkungen sondern
auch finanziell
das war eben gerade gar nicht nötig aber
auch dass es keine zwischenfrage gibt
das ist auch sofort akzeptiert worden
ich wollte es nur noch einmal für alle
sagen und gebe jetzt gerne dem kollegen
bernard herrmann das wort auch zu seiner
ersten rede für bündnis 90 die grünen
hier im haus der familie erläuterungen
bundestags vizepräsidentin katrin göring
eckardt dass bei der ersten rede die
redner nicht gleich durch zwischenfragen
unterbrochen werden
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
steigenden energiepreise sind ganz klar
das ergebnis politischer
fehlentscheidung der letzten jahre und
jahrzehnte wir erleben eine dadurch
verschuldete fossil flatz ion es wurde
verschlafen den ausbau erneuerbarer
energien voranzutreiben
die bedeutung energetischer
modernisierung wurde and gänze verkannt
die wucht dieser fossilen
versorgungskrise hätte abgefedert werden
können
es überrascht mich daher nicht im
geringsten dass die cdu csu in ihrem
antrag kaum ein wort darüber verliert
sie sehr geehrte cdu csu haben die
energie und wärme wende verschlafen
die lunte
so nun beklagten preis exklusion haben
sie doch selbst gelegt
wir sind uns einig dass steigende
strompreise und heizkosten für sehr
viele menschen zur schweren belastung
werden betroffen sind menschen geringen
einkommens aber immer mehr auch die
mittelschicht
dringend nötige kurzfristige maßnahmen
kommen und das gezielt und das ist
richtig so
lassen sie mich aber
einen wesentlichen aspekt an dieser
stelle ergänzen wenn wir bei steigender
heizkosten sprechen dann müssen wir
zugleich die geringe modernisierungs
rate von gebäuden in den blick nehmen
gebäudezustand und energiekosten gehören
doch untrennbar zusammen mehr als ein
drittel des gesamten deutschen in der
endenergieverbrauchs erfolgt im
gebäudesektor etwa zwei drittel aller
wohngebäude wurden vor dem inkrafttreten
der ersten wärmeschutzverordnung vor 43
jahren errichtet sie sind oft schlecht
gedämmt und verbrauchen bis zu fünfmal
mehr energie als neubauten die förderung
gehört in den bestand
unbestreitbar können im gebäudebereich
enorme einsparpotenziale beim
energieverbrauch erreicht werden die
neue bundesregierung richtet auch dazu
den blick nach vorne wir packen die
energetische modernisierung in dieser
legislaturperiode endlich an ab 223 wird
ein neues förderprogramm zum
klimafreundlichen modernisieren und
bauen aufgelegt und ganzheitlicher
betrachtung jede neu eingebaute heizung
soll ab 225 auf basis von 65 prozent
erneuerbare energien betrieben werden
wir sorgen endlich für mehr
energieeffizienz
beim ausbau erneuerbarer energien sind
wir schon jetzt aktiv das bmw k hat in
seiner eröffnungsbilanz die schritte
vorgegeben und wird bereits bis zum
sommer die erforderlichen weichen
stellen für das ausbauziel 80 prozent
erneuerbaren strom bis 2030 und damit
sorgen wir für eine sichere saubere und
einzig noch langfristig bezahlbare
energieversorgung
der ausweg der fossilen versorgungskrise
lässt sich nur mit einem raschen ausbau
der erneuerbaren erreichen und um eines
klarzustellen nicht in zehn jahren
werden erneuerbare preiswerter seien
bereits heute ist die preiswerte was sie
auch daran erkennen dass sie im januar
an den energiebörsen in frankreich 1 10
cent teuren strompreis gegenüber
deutschland hatten alles einschlägig da
wir packen jetzt an und stellen jetzt um
schnellstmöglich und engagiert ja wir
packen die vor uns liegenden
herausforderungen an sozial gerecht für
ein gutes langfristig bezahlbares leben
für uns aber auch dass unsere kinder
enkel und urenkel
vielen dank
das war dann die erste rede von herrmann
von den bündnisgrünen wir im deutschen
bundestag und auf indirekt antworten
wird andreas jung der sprecher für
klimaschutz und energie der
unionsfraktion auch die unionsfraktion
hat hier einen antrag eingereicht in dem
sie fordern die explosion bei den
energiepreisen zu bekämpfen und zeitnah
wirksam und gerechten zu entlasten
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das erste wort an die redner
der alv de in der tat wir werden mit ihm
niemals zusammen kommen weil wir als
christdemokraten wert überzeugungen
haben die uns fundamental von ihnen
trennen das geht ganz generell und auch
in dieser frage haben wir eine andere
haltung wir haben eine andere analyse
die explosion der energiepreise liegt
nicht an den kosten der erneuerbaren in
deutschland die liegt an einem hunger
nach fossiler energie weltweit und
deshalb ist es ja auch keine entwicklung
die sich nur bei uns im land stellt hier
auch schon die uns international
beschäftigt das ist ein erheblicher
unterschied schon in der analyse und
deshalb teilen wir die überzeugung dass
die mittel und langfristige antwort der
beschleunigte ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien ist energieeffizienz maßnahmen
sind im stück für stück unabhängig zu
werden von fossiler energie das ist
richtig den weg muss man gehen wir
werden alles was in diese richtung geht
und vernünftig ist unterstützen und
erfahren dass das was jetzt auf den weg
gebracht werden muss bei der
energieeffizienz auch beherzt angegangen
wird nach dem viel porzellan zerschlagen
wurde bei der kfw gebäudesanierung
brauchen wir jetzt klarheit wie sind die
regeln für den neubau bei effizienten
neubauten wie sie die regeln bei den
sohn ihr bei den sanierungen der reichen
nicht politische absichtserklärung der
minister wir brauchen klarheit wir
brauchen verlässlichkeit wir brauchen
regeln auf die man sich stützen kann zu
denen man anträge stellen kann und dann
ist all kollege möchten sie denn eine
zwischenfrage aus der fdp fraktion zu
lassen
bitte bitte schön
danke schön herr kollege herr kollege
jungen für das zulassung der zwischen
frage zunächst
meine großmutter fliegt dazu sagen man
soll nie nie sagen das einfach mal
vorneweg die geschichte hat auch da
tatsächlich die besteht bestätigt die
das sagen zweitens sprechen sie nicht
lieber doch von grüner inflation und ich
glaube wir fangen gar nicht erst einen
klimafragen mit ihm zu reden wenn sie
ihren grundlegenden fehler einräumen
würden sie das dann tun hals über kopf
rein ideologisch und populistisch
getrieben aus der kernenergie nach
fukushima
ausgetreten zu sein zweitens frage ich
sie würden sie einräumen dass der damm
bahn in deutschland und jungs im
handelsblatt und den vielen anderen
guten publikationen konnte man entnehmen
dass die erstens ineffizient sind und
zweitens natürlich der kollege von der
spd hat das ja auch so gesagt wird
dämmen das muss dann nämlich auch der
mieter bezahlen denn irgendwann muss es
bezahlen oder sonst der vermieter der
böse bezahlen da schon gar nicht mehr
motiviert ist und berlin überhaupt
wohnungen zu bauen drittens würden sie
mir eingestehen ich bin ein bisschen
älter ds benzin hat auch ihre partei
seit über 30 jahren zum stopfen von
finanzlöchern erst was wir erhöhen den
benzinpreis für die rente dank für die
umwelt für jeden mist haben sie
tatsächlich den benzinpreis
herbeigezogen haben dass den autofahrern
über die rübe gezogen um es mal ganz
plastisch zu formulieren und viertens
finanziert würden sie eigentlich auch
bestätigen dass im prinzip der
strompreis in deutschland nicht deshalb
so hoch ist weil grün so schön ist
sondern weil wir auch hier die
querfinanzierung der sogenannten
erneuerbaren vorgenommen haben denn wir
haben den höchsten höchsten rom preis
weltweit und das hat nichts mit der
preisentwicklung zu tun sondern mit
ihrer ideologisch getriebenen
energiewende wir haben den höchsten
energie passe sie hoffentlich das würden
wenn sie über das beantworten würden
welchen sehr dankbar die vier zwischen
es keine zwischenfragen war sind mir
eine grundsatzerklärung zur
unterschiedlichen energie und
klimapolitischen fragen ich gehe darauf
gerne ein möchte aber darauf hinweisen
dass sich die redezeiten uhr einiges
verlängern wird
erstens nein heißt nein und auch gerade
wegen unserer geschichte und unseren
wert überzeugen wir werden mit ihnen
niemals zusammen kommen das kann ich ihm
ins stammbuch schreiben
zweitens ja wir haben nach fukushima die
entscheidung getroffen aus der
kernenergie
auszusteigen
das war nicht aus ideologie sondern aus
guten gründen weil sich gezeigt hat dass
die kernenergie ein restrisiko mit sich
bringt es sich dort verwirklicht hat
dieses restrisiko ein tsunami wie dort
so was ist in deutschland nicht zu
erwarten aber auch hier was ein
restrisiko und deshalb hat man ja nicht
nicht irgendwas übers knie gebrochen
sind hat eine kommission eingesetzt die
sich damit beschäftigt hat ob es die
möglichkeit gibt
energieform voran zu bringen die diese
risiken nicht bringen und deshalb
sollten das ja nicht sofort abgestellt
sondern er hat gesagt wir nehmen uns
einen zeitraum von zehn jahren in dem
wir schritt für schritt abstellen werden
indem wir auch lösungen
finden wollen zur frage der
endlagersuche tragen sie mal zur lösung
dieser fragen bei damit haben wir uns in
kommission im bundestag beschäftigt wenn
man zwischen bundesrat und bundesrat
beschäftigt um die schwierige frage zu
lösen wo kommen diese stoffe hin die für
viele generationen noch risiken mit sich
bringen würden und deshalb unterstrich
diese entscheidung war nicht ideologisch
sie war richtig und wir halten daran
fest
dann haben sie angesprochen die frage
der verteilung der co2 kosten auf
vermieter und mieter und da will ich
sagen wir müssen ist das genau angucken
aber mir scheint auf den ersten blick
das was die regierung jetzt vorlegt ein
vernünftiger weg zu sein und es ist
übrigens ein anderer das an die adresse
von investor allen anderen in der spd
ist ist ein anderer als der den sie noch
vor wenigen monaten in der regierung
vorgeschlagen haben sie haben gesagt wir
machen immer die verteilung 50 vermieter
50 meter und wir haben gesagt es ist
doch nicht gerecht es wird im
klimaschutz nicht gerecht weil es muss
doch eine rolle spielen ob ein vermieter
ein haus saniert eine wohnung
voranbringen alles was er tut macht oder
ob es eben nicht macht und dass der der
nix macht dann gleich viel bezahlen soll
die der der alles gemacht hat dass kann
ich richtig sein deshalb finde ich es
richtig zu sagen wir knüpfen an den
sanierungs zustand der wohnung an und
vermieter der viel getan hat der macht
weniger und muss weniger bezahlen und
einer der eben nicht saniert der muss
mehr tun und umgekehrt wird damit auch
ein
dass mieter vermieter verhältnis zu
einem gerechten ausgleich gebracht das
hören wir uns genau angucken aber
scheint wegen die richtige richtung zu
gehen
dann will ich weil ich sehe dass wir
eine redezeit weiterläuft kommen zu der
frage die hier angesprochen wird wie
sind die maßnahmen zu finanzieren die
wir hier vorschlagen und ich will ihnen
sagen das was die ampel regierung in
diesem jahr plant das ist der
heizkostenzuschuss der kostet 180
millionen euro nach ihren berechnungen
und es ist die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage die noch nicht entschieden
ist aber kommen soll die kostet in
diesem jahr
00 euro ein finanzierungsbedarf von 13
milliarden euro im topf sind bereits
jetzt 12,7 milliarden bis juli wo sie es
abschaffen wollen nach ihren plänen wird
märz in sein als das überhaupt kostet
und es wird noch etwas überzählig sein
aber es sind in den in den
staatshaushalten in unserem
staatshaushalt sind mehreinnahmen über
die mehrwertsteuer sind mehreinnahmen
über den eu ets junge des
zusammenrechnet dann kommt zehnmal mehr
sogar mehr als zehnmal mehr in den
staatshaushalt rein als sie mit dem
heizkostenzuschuss zurückgeben und
deshalb muss hier mehr gemacht werden
darauf dringen wir dafür haben wir
vorschläge gemacht die sind seriös und
es kommt zusammen und jetzige
herausforderung wir brauchen jetzt
entlastung und die grundsätzlichen
aufgaben auch die des klimaschutzes
bringen wir unter einen hut und dafür
arbeiten mit diesem parlament finden
sie wollte rede von andreas jung aus der
unionsfraktion wir konnten damit zum
vorletzten redner in dieser debatte
wobei auch später ist zum beispiel ja
auch noch um den heizkostenzuschuss geht
der hier
diskutiert werden soll das heißt auch da
wird es weiter um energiepreise gehen
kann dass kaspar spd hat jetzt für seine
spd-minister
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen seit
einigen monaten erleben wir eine
zunehmende teuerung heiz und stromkosten
steigen es zeigt sich es sind die
haushalte mit geringem einkommen die
ganz besonders hart von diesen
entwicklungen betroffen sind wer ohnehin
schon wenig verdient den bleibt jetzt
noch weniger übrig nun hat die union
einen antrag vorgelegt der in seinen
titel ein großes versprechen anpreist
zeitnah wirksam und gerecht entlasten
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
von der union mit einem gerechten
vorschlag hat den antrag leider gar
nichts zu tun
er gibt vor einkommensschwache haushalte
entlasten zu wollen tatsächlich aber
kommen ihre vorschläge insbesondere
unternehmen zugute für die
energieintensive industrie wollen sie
gleich zweimal tief in die tasche des
staatshaushaltes keiten sie fordern
nicht nur eine strom steuererstattung
sondern sogar noch zuschüsse große
unternehmen würden damit viel geld vom
staat bekommen sehr geehrter
unionsabgeordnete das ist nicht nur eine
sehr fragwürdige haushaltsplanung ihre
vorschläge sind auch überhaupt nicht
glaubwürdig machen wir uns doch mal
ehrlich dieser antrag ist geschrieben
für gutverdiener und unternehmen das ist
hier in der politik aber
schieben sie doch mit dafür nicht die
haushalte mit geringem einkommen vor bei
einigen anderen punkten aus dem antrag
der union stimmen wir im ansatz über ein
klar wir müssen die erneuerbaren
energien weiter ausbauen um die
ökologische transformation weiter
voranzubringen das hätten wir aber auch
gemeinsam in der vergangenen legislatur
machen können da haben sie den
wirtschaftsminister gestellt und staaten
ständig auf der bremse
aber ich bin ja wirklich froh dass diese
fraktion jetzt wo sie in der opposition
ist endlich verstanden hat dass wir
massiv in die erneuerbaren energien
investieren müssen
aber vielleicht kommunizieren sie das
auch an ihre parteikolleginnen und
kollegen vor ort und herr jung jetzt
bitte genau zuhören da wo ich herkomme
tut die cdu alles dafür um die windkraft
zu verhindern die kreistagsfraktion im
erzgebirge und mittelsachsen wehren sich
mit händen füßen gegen den ausbau
gemeinsam mit der ard stimmen sie gegen
windkraft er merz sieht so ihre brannten
auch gegen die ard aus ihre brandner aus
nichts weiter als ein kläglicher
steinhaufen
fertig kolleginnen und kollegen der
union ihr antrag in allen ehren aber sie
sind einfach nicht glaubwürdig im
gegensatz zur union setzen wir als ampel
koalition tatsächlich die energiewende
um heute wurde bereits ausgeführt wie
wir das schaffen und gleichzeitig
haushalte mit kleineren und mittleren
einkommen entlasten
ganz zentral ist und bleibt geschaffen
die eeg umlage ab nicht wie geplant 2022
sondern schon in diesem jahr
außerdem werden wir den
heizkostenzuschuss erhöhen dies dieser
wird ja heute in erster lesung im
bundestag besprochen
liebe abgeordnete der cdu im gegensatz
zu ihnen wir machen sie auch ihre
politik die wirkt auch für kleinere und
mittlere einkommen vielen dank
palo ist kostenlos für die spd hat hier
wie gesagt den
heizkostenzuschuss schon angesprochene
wird allerdings nicht erhöht sondern er
wird einmalig gezahlt für
bedürftige im sommer soll es dafür dann
geld geben genaueres erfahren wir
allerdings in einer guten halben stunde
dann ist dieser tagesordnungspunkt an
der reihe sebastian schäfer spricht
jetzt für bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wir
führen hier eine wichtige debatte in
einer sozialen marktwirtschaft und in
einer ökologisch sozialen
marktwirtschaft zumal darf nicht die
reinen marktlogik gelten wir müssen
immer auch die verteilungswirkung der
marktmechanismen im blick haben
und der fossile energie markt wie wir
ihn gerade haben ist eben extrem
angespannt im herbst 2009 10 haben wir
uns im vermittlungsverfahren zwischen
bund und ländern zum damaligen
klimapaket überparteilich verständigt
und als die union im vergangenen
frühjahr noch in verantwortung wahr da
gab es auch interessante vorstöße aus
ihren reihen
präsidenten siege statt mehr ein zitat
aus dem r n d als konsequenz aus dem
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
klimaschutzgesetz sollten die für 2022
und 20 23 geplanten anhebung schritte
auf 30 und 35 euro pro tonne co2
übersprungen werden forderte alexander
dobrindt er ist nicht mehr da vielmehr
wolle die csu im nächsten jahr direkt
eingesprungen auf einen co2 preis von 45
euro machen der eigentlich erst 2024
vorlesen vorgesehen wäre bemerkenswert
für ihre partei und
schade wo sie jetzt mit ihrem antrag hin
gehen die absenkung der umsatzsteuer die
sie fordern hat eine völlig falsche
verteilungswirkung damit würden
vorrangig diejenigen entlastet werden
die einen hohen energieverbrauch haben
und das sind in unserem land alle regelt
diejenigen mit den höchsten einkommen
ich nenne sie mal pars pro toto die
dahlemer villenbesitzer und
es ist auch gar nicht garantiert dass
der preis dann gesenkt wird ja das hängt
wieder vom markt ab und auch die
erhöhung der pendlerpauschale die sie
vorschlagen wirkt regressiv hier werden
also diejenigen mit den höchsten
einkommen am meisten entlastet das hat
mit sozialer marktwirtschaft nichts zu
tun und geht an den nöten der unteren
einkommensschichten komplett vorbei
dieser antrag zeigt nochmal deutlich
warum ein politikwechsel in diesem land
dringend notwendig war in der letzten
dekade waren alle grundlagen da unser
land wirklich voranzubringen die
haushaltskonsolidierung ist ihnen nach
der finanzkrise mit der konjunktur
entwicklung und der lang andauernde
niedrigzinsphase in den schoß gefallen
in einem lang anhaltenden nullzinsphase
freien mitteln haben sie das geld
verpulvert für baukindergeld für
irgendwelche straßen in bayerischen
wahlkreisen unsere abhängigkeit von
russland könnte wesentlich geringer sein
wenn sie den ausbau der regenerativen
energien nicht sabotiert hätten und
diese passagen in ihrem antrag wirken
wie blanker hohn liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union die ampel geht
den fortschritt jetzt entschlossen an
natürlich hat die pandemie die situation
für uns nicht einfacher gemacht die
preise für fossile energien sind
deutlich angestiegen mehr haben in der
debatte gehört wir müssen nun diejenigen
gezielt unterstützen die am stärksten
von den steigenden preisen betroffen
sind das hat höchste priorität
wir haben einen heizkostenzuschuss
beschlossen und wir wollen die
mieterinnen und mieter mit einem
stufenmodell bei der co2 steuer
entlasten das hat die union in der
großen koalition verhindert werden die
eeg-umlage abschaffen wir geben das uns
anvertraute geld gezielt aus um unser
land zu vielen dank
ich schieße die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktionen der cdu/csu auf
drucksache 725 mit dem titel explosion
bei den energiepreisen bekämpfen zeitnah
wirksam und gerecht entlasten wer stimmt
für diesen antrag
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
damit ist der antrag abgelehnt bei
zustimmung der einbringenden fraktionen
die auf die fraktion hat sich enthalten
die anderen fraktionen haben dagegen
gestimmt
interfraktionell wird überweisung der
vorlage auf drucksache 707 an der
tagesordnung aufgeführten ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen die federführung ist
jedoch strittig sie muss auch geklärt
werden welche ausschuss sich
federführend mit den anträgen von der
afg und dann auch gleich von der
linksfraktion beschäftigt also ist es zb
er der finanzausschuss oder eher der
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie